so I had a question from someone who
made a comment on one of the YouTube
videos and they wanted to know about the
anti-aging creams if they should use
those and do they actually work and the
answer is no I'm sorry
they don't make your skin any younger
what they do is make your skin a little
bit tighter and they do add more
hydration on a temporary basis but not
actually younger and in one study which
I'll put down below found that the
anti-aging creams will reduce your
wrinkles by less than 10 percent over 12
weeks 10 percent is not even noticeable
to the human eye so you're you're not
going to really see too much so what is
the solution is there a way to reverse
the aging process or at least slow it
down and the answer is yes if you
understand the simple concept of inside
out versus outside and there's no way
you're gonna actually try to get the
body younger by applying something
topically or trying to work from the
outside in it really comes from the
inside out
and it's combination of several things
but you really want to look at the
balance of how much oxidation is going
on or things that are breaking your
tissues down or destroying your DNA
versus the antioxidants in the body
which are countering all this free
radical damage and just so you know a
free radical is an unpaired electron so
let's say for example we have this atom
right here that's supposed to be
spinning around and it only has one
electron it doesn't have the pair of
electron over here okay it's missing
what happens it makes the atom very very
unstable and so it can create
destruction to the body and an
antioxidant will donate an electron to
stabilize this to create less damage and
there's two sources of antioxidants one
is exogenous that means outside the body
from your diet you're eating leafy
vegetables you're eating cruciferous
vegetables it is giving you antioxidants
and also vitamins act as antioxidants
vitamin E vitamin A vitamin C even
vitamin b1 can
an antioxidant and they always come in
networks because when an antioxidant
donates its electron it then becomes
unstable and it can create some problems
so it will borrow an electron from
another antioxidant so they come in
networks so you have the food that you
eat with antioxidants okay that's called
exogenous then you have endogenous
antioxidants your body actually can make
and the oxidants so that's cool so the
combination of both need to be in such
quantity to counter the amount of
oxidation coming in from the environment
and from your diet that's just making
things break down and making you age
prematurely so what can make this worse
the big thing is glucose high carb diets
that will trigger insulin which will
then combine with certain proteins in
your body and cause this other phenomena
called glycation so when you combine
sugar with a protein it creates a
protein that's now non-functional and
that's going to make your your tissues
less elastic and that's going to make
you look a lot older and another term
for that is advanced glycation end
products and that is created by glucose
having a high amount of glucose in the
diet the other thing that's interesting
is nutritional deficiencies can fail to
supply certain biochemical enzymes that
are supposed to repair and keep your
tissue stable at the cellular level so
nutrition is a really key part in
slowing the aging process down faster
than it's going so the worst case
scenario is this combination between a
high carb diet and low nutrients that's
going to age your skin it's gonna make
you look older it's going to age the
inside of the body and on the flip side
of that if you switch your fuel from
glucose to ketones ketones act as an
antioxidant which is really really cool
so it's a much healthier fuel source and
I always recommend the healthy version
of the ketogenic diet so that way we can
actually add the nutrients from the food
to prevent the free radical damage and
keep your skin and your tissues looking
healthy so there's also hormones
involved they hormone that you really
want to preserve is growth hormone
growth hormone is all about anti-aging
it's all about keeping your proteins
intact and I'm talking about the skin
the hair the nails the inside of the
body growth hormone is responsible for
that as we age growth hormone goes down
we want to keep it as high as possible
so there are certain things that lower
growth hormone and there's certain
things that will increase it glucose by
the way will lower our growth hormone
insulin will lower growth hormone so
high carbohydrate diets stay away from
them cortisol from stress will also
inhibit growth hormone cortisol is very
destructive on your proteins on your
skin and it will aid you in an
accelerated rate alcohol is another
thing that is very dehydrating it will
inhibit growth hormone it will make you
look old alright so how do we raise
growth hormone well exercise okay but
make sure you don't over train if you
exercise correctly with them enough
recovery you can spike growth from about
five to seven hundred percent so that's
one key factor regular exercise plus the
exercise can if done correctly reduced
the cortisol to stress and then fast and
fasting is probably one of the most
important things if you wanted to slow
down the aging process and look younger
also when you do periodic prolonged
fasting you stimulate stem cells stem
cells actually help you regrow new
tissue like your immune system your gut
your skin so fasting is probably one of
the biggest things that can help you
look younger it can stimulate growth
hormone by thirteen hundred to two
thousand percent and then we have sleep
sleep is another key factor to enhancing
growth hormones so if you do
intermittent fasting and prolong fasting
you get enough sleep you keep your
stress down you exercise you do healthy
keto that is your best bet to slow down
the aging process but to actually think
that you can actually do it with a cream
it's just not going to
work alright guys thanks for watching
and check out a couple of these very
interesting videos I have related to
growth hormone